all right welcome to the stream this is
going to be the last stream for a while
because I'm going away for a while
people who would rather someone else
host this show are going to get their
wish because I am going to be gone for a
while we are going to talk about the
growing push to war maybe in Iran
although Donald Trump now is saying
maybe he doesn't want to go to war maybe
he does who knows he's gonna do I guess
what he thinks is the right thing and
his moral compass is completely askew so
that that's a concern from doing what he
sees is the right thing is very very
concerning for for everybody but one
angle that hasn't been discussed as much
is the fact that there's no
congressional approval for action in
Iran and according to Donald Trump's own
tweets years ago that congressional
approval that congressional
authorization would be necessary if
Donald Trump wants to take action in
Iran so we're going to get to that we're
going to look at Trump's old tweets
we're gonna look at a whole bunch of
different stuff but like I said my last
live stream for a while because we've
got tomorrow's show and then I am flying
away for a while I've got some work
stuff I'm going to a wedding and we're
going to I mean I'm just gonna be
missing for a very long time unless I
decide to stream during my trip in which
case who knows what could happen this is
a live stream of which is different from
watching clips that I've recorded
earlier in the day in that it's live
unless it's a replay meaning you can
participate you can send me questions or
comments via super chat that's the
dollar sign at the bottom of the chat
window as those come in they will pop up
on the screen I will answer the
questions I will address the comments
which is a very exciting thing
I am also willing to open the phone
lines maybe this is going to be the last
time I take phone calls for a while
other than tomorrow's broadcast show but
for a live stream this is this is it
this is your last opportunity for a
while to call in and talk to me and I
will open the phone lines if and when we
get either 10 new members or 15 new
patrons people have asked me to do
patronage because patronage starts at $1
a month whereas the membership
our I guess they start at two dollars
and eight cents a month so some people
like the idea of a dollar so if we get
ten new members on our website coupon
codes down below or fifteen new patrons
at patreon.com slash david pakman show I
will open up the phone lines and we
don't screen calls and all sorts of
interesting and unique people often call
in please don't troll the live chat to
people got banned today before the live
stream even started which is incredible
I mean it's amazing that people are able
to get themselves banned before there is
even anything to comment on but somehow
they figured it out they were able to do
it and you can also use the join button
down below to become a YouTube channel
member so let's get right into it one of
the areas that has not been properly
discussed in my opinion about the
possible push to war that Donald Trump
has been starting to hint at and create
a context for is that the president
supposedly according to what Donald
Trump tweeted a bunch of times years ago
needs congressional approval if indeed
he wants military action against Iran
and Nancy Pelosi for all of her many
faults that we've talked about for many
years and we could outline again she is
pointing this out US House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi told reporters that the
Republican administration would provide
a classified briefing for top lawmakers
on Iran later on Thursday the Trump
administration does not have
congressional authorization to go to war
against Iran the Democratic leader of
the US House of Representatives said on
Thursday amid escalating tensions in the
region
US House Speaker Nancy Pelosi told
reporters that the Republican
administration would provide a
classified briefing for top lawmakers
the so-called gang of eight on Iran
later on Thursday Saudi Arabia's Deputy
Defense Minister on Thursday accused
Iran of ordering an attack on Saudi oil
pumping stations that Yemen's
Iran aligned Houthi militia has claimed
responsibility for the attack proves
that these militias are merely a tool
that Iran's regime uses to implement its
expansionist agenda tweeted Prince
Khalid bin Salman a
of King Salman the terrorist act ordered
by the regime in Tehran and carried out
by the Houthis are tightening the noose
around the ongoing political efforts we
sort of talked about this on the Tuesday
show I believe it was the attacks took
place against the backdrop of us Iranian
tension following Washington's decision
this month-to-month who try to cut
Taran's oil exports to zero and beefed
up its military presence in the Gulf in
response to what it called Iranian
threats now that this is a really
important point to understand Iran I
have said for years I believe is a bad
faith actor that is operating in the
context of a horrible theocracy which I
oppose unconditionally right I mean no
matter whether we identify individual
good faith acts or bad faith acts by
Iran as as an entity as a geopolitical
player as a nation-state I oppose the
theocratic regime of Iran but
increasingly the United States is the
bad actor here remember that we had you
know Trump talks about he doesn't want a
war he wants a diplomatic solution well
we had a diplomatic solution in place
that Iran stuck to it's called the Iran
nuclear deal put in place by President
Barack Obama to much controversy with
much disagreement but Iran did stick to
it and when Donald Trump comes in and
says I don't I never liked the deal I
think Obama was wrong to do it so I'm
cancelling the deal you can't you know
if you uh if you get a car loan and
someone comes in later and says you know
we've bought we've bought out the car
loan company and we don't really like
that low interest rate that you were
offered so there's no more car loan I
mean either you pay us in full right now
or we up the car loan to 20% interest or
whatever that that's not how normal sort
of by two-party agreements work right
that's the whole point of them that both
parties are sticking to predetermined
requirements and Iran stuck to it so the
last thing I would want to do is someone
who does not trust the Iranian
theocratic
the last thing I would want to do is
give them any justification any context
in which they could say well if you
voided the deal without us doing
anything we're gonna go back to doing
some nuclear development now we're going
to go and try to scale up what we had
agreed not to do because why wouldn't we
at this point it's to our advantage to
do that research and it is
extraordinarily unfortunate that this is
the way it's going down let me see what
else there is with regard to
congressional approval here it looks
like not that much
so let's instead let's move on then to
Donald Trump's prior statements about
this Donald Trump August 29 2013 tweeted
what will we get for bombing Syria
besides more debt and a possible long
term conflict key line here Obama needs
congressional approval this is not the
only time that Donald Trump has pointed
this out August 30th of 2013 the day
after quote the President must get
congressional approval before attacking
Syria big mistake if he does not now
what's really important to understand
about this is that I actually agree with
Donald Trump that the president needed
congressional approval for military
action in Syria there was a case to be
made back then that there was an
authorization for military force force
that covered President Obama's actions
in Syria it's a debate okay I'm not
saying I agree with that I believe that
there should have been new specific
approval a new authorization of force
for Syria at the time that President
Obama was considering that but there was
at least an argument to be made that
there was an umbrella authorization that
you could argue covered a President
Obama's action in Syria and potential
further action in Syria there's nothing
like that right now with Iran okay and
I've heard a very flaccid argument that
there there are sort of Isis anti-isis
provisions and authorizations that would
allow Donald Trump to do this if he sort
of couches it in the right way as being
related to that no I mean there is just
no authorization here so if indeed
you agree with what President Trump
tweeted back in 2013 and I actually do
Donald Trump would absolutely need
congressional approval before going into
Iran and I don't know that he would
actually be able to get it and in fact I
think there's a good case to be made
that he probably will not owe this is
who this is a funny first response here
Dave Wiesel just a year ago you are a
blithering idiot and history will
reflect your legacy as such which is
made probably not true but but we can
hope so
this may not become I'm trying to get
out ahead of what is increasingly
smelling like looking like and feeling
like the lead up to the Iraq war that's
what I'm trying to do by pointing out
this congressional approval thing as we
may call it but we I'm trying to get out
ahead of it if indeed it becomes an
issue it may actually not and I hope
that it doesn't and from what we are
told it seems as though Donald Trump may
understand that Iran is trying to sort
of goad him or provoke him into taking
action which could be politically
disastrous it also could be politically
advantageous as we approach an election
year but yes Trump needs a congressional
approval he does not have it and it's
not clear to me that he would get it
it's also not clear to me that he would
actually go and and try to get it
unfortunately let's see what's on
people's minds here some of the super
chats that are coming in Gigi has signed
up as a new member on YouTube using the
YouTube join button down below that's
new member number one of the evening if
we get to 10 new members or 15 new
patrons I will open up the phone lines
and as usual folks are already calling
in the phone lines aren't open if the
phone lines open they will be at 6 1 7 8
3 0 47 50 but the phone lines have not
actually opened let's just listen just
just as an example here's one voicemail
that just came in from someone desperate
to get on let's take a listen ok
apparently not that desperate just
silence here's another example of
someone who's trying to get on the phone
hi David this is Mark
Newport you said that as opposed to
Elizabeth Warren's wealth tax that you
support increasing capital gains tax
rates numb as it won't force people to
sell ownership of their assets so my
question to you as a financial adviser
who desperately wants the wealthy to pay
more taxes but also recognizes the many
ways that the wealthy can get around
paying capital gains taxes yeah is don't
you think that is capital gains as
opposed to income or wealth is too
inconsistent of a source of revenue let
me know thank you okay yeah we will we
will address that mark oh this is this
is the chess guy this is actually that's
mark mark from Newport who we played
against each other in chess during a
recent livestream and maybe I would do
that if there are some like big-time
super chats or something from someone
who wants to play me--only chess org I'm
David Pakman I'm Lee chest org I would
consider doing that okay so anyway the
phone lines not yet open they may open
if we get enough members but they are
not open at this time miles Kaufman says
what is your opinion with a five-dollar
super chat of Reseda two leaves
Holocaust comments and the Ilhan Omar
controversy so I don't know I didn't see
the talib Holocaust comments I saw
headlines about it and I'm just so sick
of all of the nonsense that I didn't
even look at them so I don't even know
what she said and Ilhan Omar if there's
a new controversy I also haven't seen it
if it's the controversy I have two or
possibly three videos on it miles which
you can check out okay Joanna looper Cal
oh okay she includes her the
pronunciation even though that that's
how I pronounced it I think says most
presidents that started Wars got
reelected we are tired of war so it may
not help his reelection chances in a
time when norms keep breaking a war may
sink it I hope I wish that that was true
Joanna but I don't know that it is and I
think that a big factor in the
exploration of military action in Iran
is related to a calculation a political
calculation which is disgusting I mean
it's disgusting that political
calculations are made in which people
will lose their lives
based on an upcoming election and the
sort of timing but it's not clear to me
I mean I think that don't change horses
in midstream as stupid as it is it's
sort of help to george w bush get
reelected in 2004 it's not evident to me
that it wouldn't help donald trump get
reelected in november of 2020 i hope
that you're right and that if donald
trump does take military action in iran
particularly for political reasons when
british intelligence is telling us
there's no increased threat from Iran
doesn't mean they're there is no threat
from Iran there's a threat from Iran and
we've assessed it and it's been
relatively stable for some time there's
no increased threat right now that
justifies any of what Donald Trump is
considering doing I hope that it would
sink his reelection chances but it's not
clear to me Zenda crest says in 2016
trumpets warned Hillary wanted war with
Iran yeah I addressed that on the
broadcast show today and I pointed out
you know when you look at what's
happening with the abortion bills and
all of these anti-abortion bills that we
are now seeing in Alabama and Georgia
and Missouri I'm going to talk about on
tomorrow's show this is part of the the
the long term strategy that the right
has had obstruct Merrick garland get a
Republican in get some conservatives on
the Supreme Court to push the or pull
the Supreme Court as far to the right as
it's been in a while and then use crazy
state level of anti-abortion bills that
will be struck down by lower courts
appeal them to the Supreme Court and
then eventually it will open up the door
for an effective reversal of Rovi weight
even if roe v wade in and of itself
remains in force that would not happen
if Hillary had been elected right so for
all of those people who were saying if
it's not ex whoever I want I don't care
if it's Hillary or Trump it's the same
I'm staying home or I'm voting for some
third party candidate or whatever
Supreme Court and what's going on with
abortion right now is sort of exhibit a
of why that matters
number two yeah he'll you know I I know
that there are people who are writing to
me saying no David Hillary would also
have gone to war with Iran I don't think
so and certainly not under these
circumstances of no increased threat
from Iran I think Hillary Clinton would
listen to our allies in terms of the
intelligence British intelligence is
telling us there's no increased threat
so you can I mean certainly a Hillary
Clinton is way more hawkish than I am
there's no doubt about that there's no
denying that but right now we would not
be at risk of war with Iran under these
circumstances if Hillary Clinton were
President of the United States I didn't
vote for her for her in the primary
right just yet another disclaimer okay
let me say a big big thank you to Gordon
Pulido Gordon Pulido is new member
number two of the evening okay and as I
said at the top of the stream if people
this is my last live stream for a while
because I'm flying away tomorrow for for
a very very very long time something
like nine days anyway so if people want
to call in and it seems like people do
because the phone number is going crazy
even though it's not open it's set on go
straight to voicemail mode right now oh
boy those are a lot of even man Jimmy
from Philly let's just listen to what he
said
David Jimmy from Philly I'm going to a
trump rally in montoursville PA on the
20th of this month very very sad anyway
people going bonkers to get on the phone
I'm glad to open the phone lines if and
when we get 10 new members we have two
right now okay we have the person who
signed up on YouTube who was Gigi and
then we have Gordon Pulido and we also
have number three
Sarah tricky Sarah tricky signing up
using the very tricky coupon code safe
35 which drops a $60 membership to just
25 bucks one extra incentive I will
throw your way if you want us to open
the phone lines and sign up and you want
to call in I will give you priority on
the phone line when you sign up include
your area code in either the first name
or last name field in addition to your
name and then what I'll do is I will
write down your area code on a legal pad
that I keep with me at all times in case
I need to write anything down I'm
kidding I just keep it with me during
the show I'll write down your area code
so that when we open the phone lines I
will go to you for
okay an extra incentive to get us to 10
new members we're at 3 right now and if
we get to 10 I look forward to hearing
from lots of folks let's see what else
we've got in super chat here Brian
Ferran Miami Dolphins analytics says why
are some driven towards far-right
ideologies it depends on who you're
talking about
they're so familial politics has a big
influence over politics so it's just a
statistical reality that your politics
are far more likely to align with those
of your parents or the environment you
were raised in than to conflict although
many people abandon the politics they
were raised around number two there are
a sort of brain fear sensors and other
sort of neurological elements to being
predisposed to certain ideologies being
more or less open to difference and new
experiences and being more or less sort
of triggered by the fear of things which
can get people into far-right ideologies
lack of community I've interviewed a lot
of former white nationalists and white
supremacists and racists and all of
those folks and I have consistently
heard from them that a big factor in how
they were sort of indoctrinated was not
that they believe the conspiracy
theories about Jews or Hispanic people
or whatever but that they liked the
community element and they were just
kind of like I'll go along with whatever
these people think this is a good you
know this is a crowd that I like being
around so it's a different answer for
different people Brian and as a result
getting people out of those ideologies
also is different for everybody
Ryan Bentley says what do you think is
the possibility that Democrats are
saving impeachment in case Donald Trump
is reelected I don't know if that would
make sense I'm trying to think of
whether that would be logical so the
idea is you try to beat him without
impeachment and then you try to impeach
him if he gets reelected I don't know I
don't know if that's a logical approach
I mean I guess it depends on whether you
think trying to impeach him now would
hurt or help his chain
is a really I've been of the mindset
that at least starting impeachment
debate on the floor of the house most
people haven't actually seen the content
of the Moller report they basically have
the mindset of william bars four-page
propaganda letter so i have been
theorizing hypothesizing that if
democrats start impeachment debate on
the floor of the house that just getting
out a lot of the content of the Moller
report would damage Trump's twenty
twenty reelection chances but you're
sort of suggesting something different
Ryan it's interesting I'll think about
it a little bit more Elle Woods sends a
dollar Thank You Mitchell Guardi pay is
a new member using the join button down
below that's new member number four of
the evening and I also want to say
thanks to team on Schneider team on
Schneider or Timon Schneider I'm not
sure how the first name is pronounced
who is new member number five of the
evening taking advantage there is a
crazy coupon code that I don't even
really mention let's see if I can even
show you in the flesh let's see here
there is a coupon code that i very
rarely mention and that is a coupon code
that gives you a $35 discount off of a
yearly membership so to access I see
people in the chat saying David save
thirty five is not working invalid
coupon code etc let me just clarify for
anybody who's interested in this that
code only works on yearly memberships
okay if you're on any membership on the
monthly tab the code will not work if
you're on any membership other than
sixty dollars on the monthly tab the
coupon code will not work you must
select the $60 a year membership and hit
the signup button and then the coupon
code is save thirty five I'm not gonna
type it in because if I type in those
numbers it's gonna change the shop on
the screen but you type in save thirty
five and then it will drop the
membership from sixty dollars a year to
twenty five dollars a year okay so it's
got to be that way it won't work on any
other membership and trust me folks it's
working because T Mon Schneider just
used it and that gets us a new that's
new member number five of the evening
halfway there very quickly seems like a
lot of people do want to call in the
phone
lines are still going bananas right now
Wow
just voicemail after voicemail after
voicemail and a lot of hang-ups and a
lot of crazy stuff here's someone left a
three-minute voicemail let's see what's
up with that hey David
I know you mentioned that voter turnout
would be the best way for Democrats to
win in 2020 and you know to vote Trump
out in 2020 and I completely agree with
that but do you think we well I don't
know if we necessarily need it but okay
so this goes on for three minutes so I'm
not going to do that for you right now
but the point I'm trying to thank is a
lot of people are trying to call in and
they will be gladly welcomed on the
phones as soon as we get five more new
members okay
black wave 54 says you're was poppin
Pakman can you give some insight into
the whole Venezuelan embassy ting
dead-ass was really Gucci with it is
important orna jus heard a gang gang
Gertz
yeah I'm not familiar with that dialect
so I'm having a difficult time
interpreting the question and I didn't
hear the Venezuelan embassy ting I don't
know exactly what that is Nabil Kivar II
says why does John Bolton hate Iran so
much I was too young to know of him in
the Bush years but looking at it now it
seems super unnecessary and lacking in
any value for him and the current
administration to attack Iran yeah
there's that so you have to understand
that there is a a contingent that became
quite powerful in the lead-up to the
2003 Iraq war and during the actual Iraq
war of which john bolton was a part that
that is the p nak ok project for a new
American Century and they have their
fetishes they have their pet projects
and for many of them going into Iran
whoa my mic just turning completely the
opposite way seem to still work though I
guess I can talk into the side of it as
well but I'm not gonna do that it it
would look very weird if I did the show
like this the P Knox
or they had a number of pet projects one
of them was we want to go back into Iraq
to finish the job that wasn't done by
George HW Bush and Iran has been on
their radar as well and John Bolton now
is in a position where he potentially is
able to influence that and and he's
gonna damn well try and we've got to try
to prevent him from being able to do it
Zenda crust says if dominionist policies
like pro-life increase recession starts
violence toward immigrants worsens and
war starts I don't know about the future
of the United States yet listen I mean
we did a story today on the bonus show
about how the birth rate in the United
States is at a record low and that the
number of births last year declined for
I think it was like the fourth year in a
row or something like that and one of
the most commonly cited reasons that
people gave for why they are choosing
not to have kids is the state of
politics and that that doesn't
necessarily mean that you're right-wing
and you don't like left-wing politics
that are enacted or that you're
left-wing and you don't like Trump
that's part of it but there's this
bigger sort of fatalism I guess you
would say that is difficult to avoid
when you consider how we are destroying
the planet and you know intractable
partisanship and a lot of this other
stuff and I understand that feeling of
man if things keep going this way like
we're completely and totally screwed at
the same time I think that there is some
self-regulatory effect of our political
system now that doesn't mean that things
reverse before damage is done look at
the environment as a perfect example but
I think if the things that you're
pointing out actually happened that
there will be something else voted for
by the American public now how much
better it is remains to be seen is it
center-left pro-corporate
democratic politics versus trump or do
we get something truly you know on the
left more social democracy I don't know
and a lot of that is going to depend on
a lot of the things that happen between
now and November of 2020 and we need to
be laser-focused
on expanding the lead in the house I'm
doing a story on tomorrow's show about
how unlikely it is that Democrats will
take over the Senate but we still might
be able to get plus one or plus two in
2020 and obviously we're moving Donald
Trump
Shane babka I'm planning actually on my
upcoming trip I'm planning on having
some chocolate babka which is a just
might one of my favorite desserts if row
is overturned will gay marriage be next
not necessarily no I don't think so I
think that so the roe v-- wade is from
1973 and there are ways that you can
undo the impact of roe v wade you can
overturn it in spirit without
overturning it legally speaking by
getting a favorable finding by the
Supreme Court which then allows all
sorts of state-level bans to be voted in
and upheld with gay marriage it's a
little bit different and I think it
would be much more difficult to overturn
it in the same way because the whole
approach for these state-level
anti-abortion bills is that they try to
have a focus that in legally speaking
even though we see it as roe v wade
legalized abortion they want to make it
illegal they're trying to focus it
legally in a way that it could slide
through without roe v-- wade having to
be overturned and with gay marriage it
would be far more difficult I think the
anti-gay battle lines now are on the on
the lines of religious freedom and the
freedom to continue to fire people for
their perceived or actual sexual
orientation and other so-called
religious freedoms like not not serving
gay people at your business that's where
the battle lines currently are Shane rme
says why do you insist on indulging
Jimmy's lunacy I find him kind of funny
I don't know I mean I know that Jimmy
from Philly is very controversial from
the audience and I see a lot of these
comments that people will often post
when we hear from him but I find the guy
interesting and in some sense and it's a
it's a direct line into true Trump post
mania and I find that sort of
interesting okay I want to welcome new
member number six of the evening Miguel
Gonzalez Cedeno has signed up using the
absolutely brutal discount a save 35
save 35 as a discount
code that will take a $60 membership it
starts with a $60 membership and it
whittles it all the way down to a $25.00
a year membership that's two dollars in
eight cents a month okay now to address
this this is actually a good opportunity
to address this last a super chat Jimmy
is a member okay
Jimmy from Philly is an absolutely fever
--nt look that one up on urban
dictionary a fever n't Trump estai mean
completely unhinged in every way and yet
the fact that I have shown respect to
him as an individual although I do not
even remotely respect his political
views
Jimmy has signed up for a David Pakman
show membership okay if 2% of the
progressive audience if the David Pakman
show signed up for a membership we would
be laughing our way away from depending
on YouTube revenue and sponsorship
revenue because Jessica we estimate like
1% of our audience
supports the show financially it might
even be like point 75 percent of the
audience if we could just get the 2
percent of our progressive audience
supporting the show we would be
financially soluble regardless of what
happens with YouTube D monetization
Jimmy conservative Jimmy is a member
paying three dollars and 60 cents a
month okay if you like the show if you
support the show if you think that the
show is valuable and you want the show
to reach as many people as possible the
save 35 coupon code effectively works
out to two dollars in eight cents a
month and most people in the audience
can afford that if you can't don't sign
up okay if you genuinely can't afford
two dollars in eight cents a month I
don't want your money but if you can the
right thing is to support media outlets
that we like and agree with and Jimmy is
doing it I think a lot of a lot of folks
are able to do it if we get just four
more members I will open up the phone
lines tonight okay of some very
interesting super shots coming in Nouvel
coasts which i think means new thing in
French I'm going tomorrow to a place
where French is spoken and I will be
speaking French as a Tesla investor do
you feel electric cars are oh no shows
is a thing in French so I don't know
what that means
you've something as a Tesla investor do
you feel electric cars are the greenest
transportation option how about public
active transport or hybrids what do you
use yeah I currently use public transit
whenever I can and then I will use
ride-sharing when parking is not
convenient and I will sometimes drive my
car I don't currently have a hybrid or
an electric car I've had hybrids before
there were questions with hybrids about
the batteries in them and the fact that
fossil fuels are required both to make
the batteries and then that the disposal
of them may sort of counteract the
effect of the gas mileage advantage
unless you're driving some crazy number
of miles per year so I think that
electric is great if we can sort out the
battery production piece and if we can
get our electric grid off of dirty fuel
right because using electriss--
electrical ectric city generated by
fossil fuels yes i think it is still
better based on the research i've seen
but it doesn't totally solve the problem
now as a Tesla investor you know
honestly I have not even looked at Tesla
stock at this point since I sold half of
it a while ago let's even take a look
TSLA stock let's see how it's doing so
it's at 228 when did I sell well I mean
I don't try to time the market but it
seems maybe I made the right decision
I think I might have sold might have
sold around this time around 3 I think I
sold around 325 I sold half of it and
now we're down to 2 Wow so I haven't
even looked at this for a long time I
guess maybe I made the right decision
although my philosophy on investing is I
don't try to time the market
I mostly in mutual funds and I don't try
to time the market so regardless of my
Tesla investment which apparently I
guess have a bite by sheer luck made the
may be the right decision by selling
half of it
regardless of that I think that we
should be number one moving off of
fossil fuels number two I actually the
most interesting proposal to me is
electric vehicles with electricity that
does not come from fossil fuels that are
Auton
the shared because most people have
their cars parked 95% of the time and if
we could have sort of a just-in-time
autonomous system where you need a ride
and the car picks you up and then it
picks someone else up and then there's
no there's not all these cars driving
around and sitting around that's the
best thing in my mind although it is
pretty ambitious at this point in time
let me thank a couple of other new
members or one new member hey soos
Mendoza is new member number seven of
the evening okay if we get three more
new members I will open the phone lines
I think we should do it I think we
should do it because this is the last
time I'm gonna be doing a stream and
potentially taking calls until I get
back from my trip which is a combination
work trip and pleasure trip
so I say we open the phone lines we just
need three more new members and then we
will we will do that Shawn Geiss says
have you ever read Stephen Kinzer Zoar
Stefan Stephen Kinzer is overthrow I
have not it's an intriguing and
informative book about how the US
government from Hawaii to Iraq
successfully overthrew their governments
and the tactics used and people involved
I have not read that and I already have
a bunch of books a small stack not a
huge stack but I've got a bunch of books
that I'm bringing with me on my trip to
read on the planes and in transit
between places but I'll add it to my
list of maybe further into the future to
read Jackson says what is your favorite
lesser-known policy of Andrew Yang's you
know I couldn't really say offhand
really putting me on the spot here
Jackson I am Not sure I'll get back to
you on that Rock Lee is our newest david
pakman show member using YouTube's
membership platform which is fine with
peace and love all memberships are
welcome just remember YouTube takes 30%
of the membership fee our website takes
only 2.9 percent to process payments so
just something to keep in mind and also
Michael Davis has signed up for a new
membership on our website that is new
member number
9 so we have now we're only one new
member away from opening up the phone
lines and I see that the voicemails
continue to flow in we may get the phone
lines opened if we get just one more new
member who's it gonna be
and if you want to get right on the
phone with me when we open the phone
lines include your area code in the
first or last name field and then you
will get priority treatment okay
Zenda crust says are you a fan of George
strombone michael brooks george strombel
not seen anything of his four years and
Michael I know personally but I don't
know that I've ever seen his show so I
know him personally and he's a nice guy
but I his actual work I don't think I've
ever seen his program other than maybe a
few minutes when he had Anna kasparian
on and they were talking about Dave
Rubin but otherwise I've not seen
anything that either of these folks has
done for a very very long time okay we
have our tenth member and our tenth
member is Ryan M Ryan M has signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership so I
am going to be true to my word and open
up the phone lines for everybody at six
one seven eight three zero 4750 you can
start calling in now I will wait a
little bit for the phone lines to get
filled up and for people who don't know
the reason that we do the membership
drive to open the phone lines when I do
live streams is the phone system
actually cost money and when we have as
we often do lately 30 40 50 or even as
many as 60 people who are holding as we
take calls we're paying for every single
one of those people who's holding and it
starts to add up we have had record
phone bills basically every month now
dating back like six or seven months so
to account for that we do a little
membership drive whenever I do extra
phone phone calls phone line opening so
that's the the source of that okay a six
one seven eight three zero
4750 is the number I am going to very
very shortly get to those phone calls
and curious what is on people's minds
let's see here I'm getting myself dialed
into the system and I think we're
basically ready to go so let's see why
don't we start today with let's go this
is an interesting one this is someone
we've not heard from since December a
lot of last year and in the notes it
says New Jersey Boston College graduate
student is that does that ring a bell of
to you whoever this is hello yes that's
you oh okay all right I got just a Brina
that's what so sorry exactly one of our
moderators so you're from New Jersey
these are interesting notes that we have
in our system yeah I'm from New Jersey I
moved to Boston to go to PC I just
graduated right congratulations like a
non-political random question sure and
then I'm going to have questions for you
as well by the way are you into
self-help books at all not really no
let's see the closest thing to self-help
books I've read so I recommended the
book by journalist Dan Harris on the
show yesterday or the day before called
10% happier which is about how he found
mindfulness meditation and befriended a
lot of interesting like big meditation
gurus and I read it not really as a
self-help book and I don't even know
that it is a self-help book but more
about a guy in the media who had a
nervous breakdown on air so that I've
read some of some of the stuff by
Eckhart Tolle I think that's how he
pronounces his last name although it's
very woowoo for me but I've just heard
it was interesting so I checked that out
but no I don't really read self-help
books mm-hmm okay so like with me I'm
just sort of like struggling I mean I
just start the job I guess I don't
really know how to handle my finances so
like it seems like you're really good
with your finances and you know all
those things so what would you suggest
for like a starter like how do I go
about handling yeah so here's my soul
okay so two things number one I would go
to the blog mister money mustache mister
money mustache is the blog
name of a guy named Pete Adney who we've
had on the show and just go back to the
archives go to the very I once read his
entire blog when I got into him some of
the things are a little bit exaggerated
like you don't need to go as crazy as he
suggests but that's a really good
framework but a couple things are
basically if you don't have a thousand
dollars saved outside of your sort of
day-to-day expenses for an emergency
consider that an emergency that needs to
be your number one priority consider
every single bill that you have and your
budget and really consider whether it
makes sense to make those expenditures
or to maybe build up initially the
thousand dollars and eventually a
six-month emergency fund look at what
debt you have and explore what of it is
necessary I mean this is all all the
stuff is outlined by mister money
mustache but that's one of the better
personal finance bloggers that I
recommend okay thank you
yep okay so and Sabrina here's my
question for you how many people are you
finding that you have to ban on YouTube
every time there's a live stream oh not
maybe about two or three at least okay
what is it that they're usually doing
that gets them banned well say very
obvious totally things like I had one
commenter say something against user you
know the usual yeah okay so there's
nothing it's just like the normal stuff
you see in the YouTube comments on
videos you're seeing it in the chat and
you just are kibosh in it exactly very
good okay all right very good well
Sabrina appreciate your help moderating
all right thank you okay great take care
let me welcome two new members mark ask
you or ask you and Eric Kreeger thanks
to both of you mark using the this is 20
20 40 percent discount
Eric using the safe 35 discount off of a
$60 membership very very good appreciate
that
let's go next to where are we gonna go
next let's go to the lot of new area
codes we're taking calls by the way at 6
1 7 8 3 0 47 50 let's go to the 3 6 1
area code who's
calling today from 361 hi David can you
hear me yes I can who's this hi this is
Rolando I'm from Corpus Christi hey
how's it going Rolanda hi um I was just
wondering what you thought about
introducing standards for argumentation
within like I guess like a legislature
setting like I noticed that you had like
a series on like logical fallacies and
stuff you know I mean yes and I was
thinking maybe it would be helpful if we
saw outlines of arguments and like you
know like if that statement and like
listed like assumptions of arguments
like whenever people are arguing unlike
the Senate and stuff yeah I understand
your motivation for that because you
have a mind I'm inferring where it's
very easy to get pot caught up in like
political and rhetorical speech and sort
of like not understand the crux of an
argument in that logically in sort of
the format of formal logic the problem
is that I think we're gonna have an
engagement problem because for a lot of
people having to read through every
single political argument in sort of the
formal logic notation you're suggesting
is gonna be a big glazed-over factor I
could I can see that I just thought that
maybe it would be good to have record of
what people like argued you know I mean
well we have records I just think
they're not in formal logic notation the
way you're suggesting okay well yeah
thanks for answering my question
my pleasure great to hear from you
Rolando appreciate it let me get to a
couple of super chats that have come in
Eris is love says do you think we could
be approaching a time in our history
where the best option is to split into
two nations help Erik is gumming mottos
okay I don't know what that last part
means but and I don't know who or what
Erik is but it's a very very interesting
super chat I mean listen there there is
already a case to be made that there are
regions of the United States that are so
culturally differ
that they easily could be different
countries I think that there would be an
intangible negative effect of the United
States breaking into multiple countries
that I would not like to see but
certainly I feel like my life in
Massachusetts has nothing to do with the
life of a rural Oklahoman in terms of
culture in terms of economy in terms of
opportunities in terms of you know media
consumption and even what national
priorities should be so I think that it
wouldn't be totally illogical to do that
but I think it would be very very
damaging and in practice it would also
be financially destructive for red
states a big picture Jess L says what's
the best way to talk politics with Trump
people depends what you're trying to do
if you're just trying to be respectful
and avoid a fight don't volunteer your
own politics just listen politely but if
you want to sort of engage in a
conversation I think there's a couple
good tools one is ask so here's I got
this from Jay Tomlinson from best of the
left podcast who I saw yesterday
actually here in Boston and he's given
this to me before he says a really great
thing at the beginning of a conversation
with people who very much disagree is
imagine that you're talking about
healthcare right you should say great I
want to talk about this issue with you
and what I think would be useful before
we start is you you have a sense of what
my position is tell me why you think I
hold the position I hold right and see
if they attribute your position to good
faith or bad faith
most people will attribute your position
to good faith so somebody who doesn't
want single-payer health care or
whatever i if I most people if I say to
them tell me why you think I do want
single-payer health care most people
even if they disagree
are going to say something along the
lines of well I
you probably want single-payer health
care because you think it's the best way
to get the best care to the most number
of people and that is immediately going
to sort of restructure the frame of the
debate in a much less negative way it
doesn't mean you're going to agree on
the policy you want but that's an
interesting thing that I think is useful
and then you go to the de feasibility
question which is what evidence if now
that you've established what my position
is and why I have my position whether
what evidence if I could present it to
you would make you reconsider your
position and maybe come over
to my position and I think that that's a
really great way to start conversations
in general with people that disagree
with you let's pick up next on our
caller from the eight for three area
code who's calling from eight for three
today hi David this is Chris from Texas
hey Chris what's going on I have a
question about education you know
progressives are very interested in
having free college tuition but one
problem that's not really talked about
is that our high school education is far
beyond is far behind the rest of the
world yes what are some things you think
we could do to improve our high school
education well it needs to number one
actually be funded properly in every
state and there are states where as a
result of a combination of deliberate
attacks on public education various
types of voucher schemes and and many
other reasons and just general you know
bad bad budgeting at the state level
particularly by red states but public
education is just not even remotely
funded at the level that it should be
the student to teacher ratio is not
appropriate the buildings are falling
apart
etc so just dealing with that alone
would be a big step forward but then
when it comes to curriculum I believe
that we need to start teaching critical
thinking philosophy and go back to
teaching civics and government in places
that have stopped teaching it
immediately at the sixth or seventh
grade level and that is going to much
better prepare students both for college
and for the real world I think that's a
great idea and you know especially here
in the South there's a lot of a lot of
schools don't want to fund science
education which is just a huge huge
problem
that is absolutely disastrous problem
and then I think you know anytime you
talk about teachers it starts to get a
little touchy but what you have to
understand is a lot of the younger
teachers that are teaching now who are
my age and younger they never were
taught this stuff either right so so we
now have a generation of teachers that
never had critical thinking and
philosophy and all of these other topics
and that's just as much of a problem as
the students not being taught it
exactly well thanks for taking my call I
love the show and just thankful all
right Chris from Texas thanks so much
great to hear from you
we're taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
a couple of other super chats Nate who I
presume is from Canada or at least is
transacting in Canadian currency says
David your last sit-down with Jesse Lee
Peterson was amazing please talk to him
again I need more of that in my life
I am tentatively working on a big big
big event maybe big big if a lot of you
people show up with Jesse Lee Peterson
which hopefully I can announce in the
next like three to three to four months
and Eris is love says I appreciate your
thoughtful answers thank you let me go
next to the six one zero area code who's
calling today from six one zero okay my
name is Paul and I'm also from Philly
hey Paul from Philly what's going on not
too much man I do really appreciate
listening to you I promise to keep the
call civil everything I really think you
have a gift of gab and it's really
evident in the way you communicate so I
have a question sort of about
communication itself so okay I'll just
say you see communication about politics
as the - no I don't think that I mean
that's a very that's an absolute the
highest intellectual goal I don't know
that it is communicating about politics
I think politics does affect our lives
even if you don't care about politics
politics still affects your life unless
you I don't know live a sort of like
ascetic isolated rural life or whatever
so I do think that communicating
effectively about politics is a high
priority but I'd have to think about
what I think is the greatest form of
communication in that sense I you know I
don't think that it's you know the way
you you do speak very very clearly about
the way you feel about your ethics and I
did like that I meant with the last
caller one before that where you were
saying that you know we should teach the
kids civics or government at a much
younger age like I totally agree with
these
these points of view and like that's
where I'm saying like how I like it my
question really comes down to do you see
what you're doing as an art as a live
stream or on YouTube or whatever your
platforms are I'm new to you I mean
listen I'm not here calling myself the
next van Gogh but I do think that if you
ask me is effective communication and
art earth science I do think it's a
combination of both okay yeah all right
my pleasure great great to hear from you
appreciate the phone call let's go next
to the 6:09 area code whose calling
today from six zero nine six zero nine
are you there I heard a little noise
there hello yes that's you who's this oh
my god oh okay and this is a little bit
off-topic and I get which I'll say it
about the school but you know what rate
is pretty high if any of the candidates
talk about well Elizabeth Warren has a
plan that she claims will reduce rent by
ten percent over ten years and create
1.5 million jobs I don't know if you've
seen that I have not cleaned up but I am
happy because you know hard out here and
I think that people should we should
really be thinking about technologies
for the earth like we're probably on our
way to being remus to at this point let
me ask you this and by it was so first
did I catch your name I'm sorry Kristen
okay and where are you calling from
Kristen calling from Delaware Delaware
okay Kristen is there anything you could
do to make your audio more consistent
because it's going from extreme you can
hear me now okay good so listen Kristen
are you in a very high cost of living
part of Delaware yeah Ronald corner
there's an apartment that's like 1800 a
month different and that's a
three-bedroom and there are places in
Delaware that go up to 15
hundred just for a three-bedroom and
you're lucky if you can get a 12 too
much and I was just speaking to someone
today because I'm an uber driver and he
says his rent is 1,900 a month in New
York right yeah I mean I live in Boston
and when you say 1800 for a
three-bedroom that sounds that that
would be gone in a minute the minute it
goes on Craigslist because that's that's
you know in Boston that would be
considered very inexpensive but I
understand that Boston's an extremely
expensive place it is yep so in New York
New York is getting expensive all around
them all across the border our wages are
going down they're not really going up
all per se but well they're stacking and
as cost of living goes up you know your
effective wage is in a sense lower yeah
right listen this is a big problem and I
would check out Elizabeth Warren's
affordable housing proposal it's it's
something you know and again it's a
long-term plan and she hasn't no votes
have been cast yet but it's a it's an
idea no it's just that's one of my
things that was I'm really passionate
about just getting like rent under
control because it compresses as it is
right now the only one have people to
move into these places
absolutely absolutely all right Kristen
very much appreciate the phone call okay
YouTube take care let's see why don't we
go next to our caller from the 502 area
code who's calling today from 502 hey
what's up David Scott from Kentucky
Emily we spoke to a few months back we
probably don't remember talking about TV
pilot Roberts but anyway no start Scott
okay gotcha what's going on today Scott
alright so uh I just know when to follow
up I know and talk about the old Alabama
stuff that's going on at the moment and
I just it's just been bothering me that
you know a lot of centrist Democrats are
or maybe just Center left or people who
claim to be soon or left haven't really
been given it the attention deserves or
you know three months ago they'll be
like oh whoa I'm a I'm a liberal but I
think that all this stuff going
New York is terrible but you know right
now they're making videos like oh look
at this silly reactions from Alyssa
Milano and ALC and stuff and does not
really actually paying attention to the
bill in question and still she you know
I'm still going out of the way that
defend the Conservatives attacking of
course because they share office
interest in the press they're always the
victims so some is of the centrist
Democrats because they're miss dating
what's in the bill or III I don't know
that I understood your question brother
on okay for example three months ago in
regards to that at a temple interview
you had a low back about three months
ago he uploaded a video that was like
you know New York is proposing this
barbaric you know abortion bill would
allow like a post birth abortion quote
and of course I mean I disagree with
that too fundamental as I said but me
but he claims to be pro-choice and you
know a lot of liberals that claim to be
pro-choice and that with all this going
on right now they're still like oh look
at listen a lot Milano silly stick
striking all this and but not actually
no fighting back when they claim to be
pro-choice Scott I'm not gonna lie I
don't know what you're talking about
um
okay simple made a video three months
ago yeah he was attacking the New York
bill right and and then recently he made
like two or three videos you know going
after Alyssa Milano and alt about their
kind of silly responses to the to the
Alabama bill okay instead of actually
going after the Alabama bill I see what
you're saying so you're saying if Tim
Poole is against abortion and there's
this Alabama bill you know he's
pro-choice but he doesn't stick up for
you know a lot of other abortion right
you're saying it would be better for him
instead of criticizing Alyssa Milano's
response to the bill to go after the
bill because that's really the problem
yeah and and you know all this other
paint
SJW news and stuff like that you know
when you have issues that you supposedly
support you know instead of actually
speak
now for them because you know knowing
these almost a hundred percent of your
audience is conservatives but here I
guess one of those Trojan horse liberals
that supposedly support things but do
you have any opinion on that I don't
want to start any drama I really don't I
really don't but it's really a pleasure
to hear from you again and these are all
issues I gonna be following and taking
under advisement for note for sure and
for the long term yeah and it's not just
a mass loss vote liberals but sardonyx
just but yeah appreciate talking anybody
is doing okay Scott take care very good
great to hear from you okay let me look
at a couple of other super chats here
that have popped up
let me see dark hey imp says sorry if
it's unfair to ask you to weigh in on
but would writing in Sanders Warren if
neither wins the nomination be bad or
tantamount to voting third party yes I
mean in in swing states if someone else
is the nominee and you write in Sanders
Warren you're helping Trump I mean
that's just the pragmatic reality we can
have a discussion about the ethics of it
but that is the practical reality Travis
the human says abortion ban seemed to be
more about political long game long
games than fetus rights Republicans will
pass dead bills if they can smear the
leftist and liberals you know I wish it
was just about smearing leftists and
liberals but passing dead bills is
actually about trying to get something
to the Supreme Court and it's a pretty
damn clever strategy that may actually
work why is my phone going off I could
have sworn I silenced it okay
I didn't interesting Elya women out
women now women now I hope I'm
pronouncing that correctly on the topic
why is the right to housing not a thing
home one homeless to rising rent three
people need work for 2008 yeah I mean
it's um I think there's the perception
that it is less of an immediate issue
than health care for the left although
there are people who are big in the pro
you know the housing movement so I
should think about I don't know why it's
not seen as as big of an issue because
it is I mean everybody needs a place to
live most people need health care but
there are periods in people's lives
where they're relatively healthy and
sort of don't not a defense of
supporting one thing over the other but
that is interesting choco flavored
cookies 56 has just got here do you
think a fetus is a life a fetus is a
form of life but I think the more
relevant question in the context of
abortion is whether it is a person and I
think that you cannot make the argument
that a fetus is a person until later on
in the gestational period of Homo
sapiens which lasts about nine months so
I think that very often the the the
debates over whether a fetus is a life
to me don't answer the question of what
should abortion laws be Maximilian
Richter says have you read capitalism
socialism and to call capitalism
socialism ecology and what are your
thoughts on reducing work hours and
ending labor as a commodity instead
using ubi and or income not based on
hours worked so time can be devoted to
unprofitable acts I have not read
capitalism socialism and ecology I am in
favor of radically reworking the
workweek you know on the David Pakman
show we have done a bunch of different
things we're not fully on a four at
four-day Work Week
but we have a combination of sort of
some flex time in the roles that allow
it combined with Friday not being a
regular production day and we're toying
around with different things and I'm
open to ubi and I'm supportive of
certain implementations of it I'm open
to income that becomes disconnected from
hours worked and and in fact you know we
have both hourly and salaried people on
staff and with hourly people I mean it's
literally hourly so you're a little more
restricted but with salaried people we
were sort of testing a lot of these
different things so yeah I I'm very much
in the sort of reworking work movement
inconsolable says David I've been trying
really hard to catch your shows and
become a member but I can't find
information anywhere on what time your
show is on well the broadcast show is
produced in the afternoon and then
published so it's not live in that sense
so you know that there's no particular
live time to become a member you just go
to our website and sign up that's really
easy and then the
livestreams are sort of ad hoc when I
kind of feel like it and have time
usually a couple of weekday evenings at
either 6:00 or 7:00 Eastern black sends
a dollar
Ariel Fernandez says who wrote the
original u.s. Pledge of Allegiance I
have no idea
booger stink plop sends ten dollars and
Nate says what are your thoughts on the
n-word I'm black and I don't really take
much of an issue with whites using it in
a non derogatory context who do you
think should say the word only blacks
everyone or no one yeah I mean I don't I
don't use the word myself and I think
that there is something to the idea that
it's very dicey for non blacks to use it
I you know I am NOT into language
policing I am NOT into authoritarianism
of that type so I don't use the word and
I think when other people use it
regardless of their race you have a
pretty good sense via intuition whether
it's you know a discriminatory or
insulting use of the word okay let me
try the eight seven zero area code who's
calling today from eight seven zero hey
David this is Logan from Arkansas hey
Logan what's going on Oh
so mmm I'm 17 I'll be voting in the
upcoming election great
but sorry I'm sick but one thing they
have noticed that are causing media
outlets haven't really focused on is the
I guess my generation perception of
things which I mean I understand why
that wouldn't be their focus but I guess
I'm just really worried that there's
kind of a react
um I don't have evidence behind this
this your conjecture but that my
generation is kind of reactionary right
and that they kind of embrace by kind of
a white identity politics or or like we
grew up with the popular thing is all
the wet YouTube channels
bashing the sjw's right and so mmm yes
not really being aware of substance yes
well that that's a problem but is there
is there I'm not sure I know what your
question is necessarily mmm well mmm
and what one example of it is and just
that online characters such as like Alex
Jones Breitbart and like you have stuff
I'm fortunate and stuff yeah there's
there's just kind of an internet culture
that we've grown up with and also like
growing up after 9/11
yeah I'm sorry this is kind of a side
tangent but I've noticed like there's
not an anti-war movement in my
generation at all like there was in
Vietnam right well no but now I'm
wondering was the anti-war movement
during Vietnam seventeen-year-olds that
is a fair point but I mean like as far
as it was a lot of college to do that
yes like I can't say you had high scores
at the colleges but em I gotta say that
from when I talked to people online and
stuff their perception just generally
seems to be that oh well a lot of them
don't even know that we're at war but if
I ever bring up like how are the war
crimes going on in Yemen or anything
like that one they're usually not aware
to they don't really seem to care about
it well listen it's a couple different
things number one when you're 17 and you
can be drafted when you turn 18 you're
going to be much more aware of what's
going on with the military than when
you're 17 and there is no draft and that
that's one issue the other is you know
in general seventeen year olds are not
the most engaged group with politics as
a sort of general rule so I think
there's a couple different factors there
Logan I'm sorry this kind of sporadic
but it's my perception is just that
there is from from what I've observed
which
live in Arkansas so maybe my perception
skewed but by people my age they look at
Trump and they think oh he's cool
fashion all the all the Lib [ __ ]
right the popular in fall well that's
why we're in trouble and Arkansas is a
very red state and Tom cotton my senator
right
Logan listen I got a run but I
appreciate the phone call great that
you're engaged at seventeen years old
really appreciate that
okay Arielle Fernandez says that Francis
Bellamy wrote the Pledge of Allegiance
very very good new veljko says is there
a story with your stubble liners that a
new style I just noticed that I don't it
there's like a line of on my beard and I
have no idea what that is and it's bad
it's really bad on this side it's not
happening but they're there does appear
and you know I think it's not like when
I look in the mirror I don't see it but
it almost looks like my mustache is
extending all the way back almost to my
neck this is horrible
I'm fully shaving tonight though in
advance of my trip because I do my beard
it's so pathetic my beard goes so grows
so slowly that if I take a trip that's
like under two weeks I can just shave
like the day before the trip and then
not bring any shaving stuff which is
great just less stuff that I have to
pack black sends a dollar super chat and
then a ten dollar super chat saying I'm
a teen in high school and I'm in the
Navy and listen process the military is
my only way out of poverty this Iran
situation as my nerves worked up I'm not
scared just angry Bolton will kill us
all I sympathize with that and I
understand also the military of being
your most direct path out of poverty I
do understand that calling some time
that I'd be interested to hear more
about that Hasan jf says what did you
think of Liz Warren's tweet where she
said we should rely on the military to
fight fight climate change I didn't see
it but you know the Pentagon actually
understands that climate change is a
national security issue and the military
also seems to get that and I actually
think it's an interesting idea
dusty Dark Horse says I don't want
Bullock to stop being by my governor
Ariel Fernandez says that France
Bellamy was a Christian socialist and
Sox fan 2:23 says I heard destiny speak
about abortion being legal but unethical
I feel conflicting intuitions generally
should I commit to obscurity artisan
manipulations or pursue encompassing
centrist solutions you need to apply
pragmatism to what you're doing
but I don't think that centrism is the
path forward by any means III don't
think abortion is unethical I just think
it would be great to get rid of a but
get rid of abortions as a necessity and
right now they are necessary and so they
should be legal and safe but I also
agree like it would be great I don't
like abortion as something women have to
consider doing because we know that it
is not something that they do which has
absolutely no impact whatsoever it is
something that has an emotional impact
and otherwise effects women and men who
are in a partnership for example or have
been in a sexual relationship that leads
to that conversation so I don't I don't
call it unethical but I think it would
be great to reduce the number of
abortions to 0 if practically possible
ok I've got a run cuz I got a busy day
tomorrow and then I'm flying out so I'll
try to stream from my trip if possible
it may not be but thanks to everybody
who joined me really apprec--